what's up everybody welcome back to my
channel Richard on data if this is your
first time here my name is Richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this and hit the
notification bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video so I did a
video a couple weeks ago about whether
or not data science is going to die in
the next five years and now I don't
think that it will but I highlighted
that one of the key problems is how
ambiguous the definition of data science
is specifically there's no clear
boundaries for what does and does not
constitute data science you've got some
people in the statistics community
saying that data science is just a fancy
made-up term for what they've been doing
all along you've got a certain brand who
thinks that data scientists are people
who know 17 programming languages the
list goes on and on I concluded that
video by saying in the future you might
start to see more specialization you
might see more machine learning
engineers you might also see more
business analysts so I thought what
better time to address another question
which comes up a lot which is what
exactly is the difference between a
business analyst and a data scientist so
we're going to look at for those two
roles what you can generally expect as a
usual disclaimer this is based on my own
experience and research as well as the
anecdotes of people in my network your
career is a super important thing for
which you should always do your own
research so take this video to give you
some helpful food for thought as well as
for entertainment purposes we're going
to look at the following things number
one how do you define these roles and
what exactly are they what are the
educational requirements for each of
these roles the thing that everybody
cares about and that's money what does
the future look like for each of these
roles and then how exactly should you
decide which one you want to get into
let's start with the definition of a
data scientist now I did a whole video
on what I think a data scientist is but
the TLDR of that or I guess the TL DW in
this case is a data scientist is
somebody who's an expert across
for different things statistics
programming domain expertise and
communication skills and you're going to
have some strengths and some weaknesses
in fact everyone does but those are the
general four skill sets that a data
scientist is going to have now depending
on who you talk to you might hear
different definitions but to me that's
what a data scientist is business
analysts are a little bit more well
defined so the International Institute
of business analysis defines a business
analyst as an agent of change
they enable change in an enterprise by
defining needs and recommending
solutions that deliver value to
stakeholders and naturally because this
is the 21st century and we live in an
enormous lis digital era that's going to
be massively driven by data you will see
the term data analysts get floated
around a lot too and in some cases this
term and business analysts are fairly
interchangeable especially with smaller
companies but in the aggregate there is
a difference between the two they are
similar but distinct with data analysts
typically having more focus on data and
business analysts having more
comparative focus on processes and on
business now let's think about the core
skill sets that I mentioned for data
scientists now I would argue that for
business analysts it's even more
important to be really strong with
domain expertise and communication
skills domain expertise should make a
ton of sense
I mean if your job is to be an agent of
change for a particular business but you
don't understand the current state of
that business or the reason things are
the way they are today you're going to
run to a lot of problems and
communication is the same sort of deal
because a big part of your life will
involve analyzing data in order to tell
compelling stories but once you go from
data to story you need to know how to
actually well tell the story some
statistical foundation is going to be
important as well but it doesn't
necessarily need to be crazy or
technical I'd say some helpful things to
know would be all
the different types of bias statistical
tests confidence intervals the
hypothesis testing framework linear
models basically things like that which
aren't super complex but provide a
really good foundation for thinking
through problems statistically then for
programming that's going to depend a
little bit now one thing which is going
to be super common is sequel because at
the end of the day you're not going to
escape the fact that you need to query
your data and get it into a unified form
before you can do anything else
and for some your other go-to is gonna
be Excel now I have a whole video about
why I think it's best to use an open
source programming language and that
goes for business analytics as well I
personally hate using Excel for any type
of analysis that lasts more than a
couple minutes but in all fairness Excel
is all over the business world it has
been for many many years and I really
don't think that's gonna change anytime
soon so now that we've talked about some
definitions for these terms and what
exactly they are let's talk a bit about
the requirements for each of these
positions from an educational standpoint
starting with data science most people
getting in this field are going to have
advanced education and that's probably
gonna be in statistics mathematics or
computer science and alternatively
universities often have special data
science programs now too as well but
from this 2019 burch work study they
found that 47 percent of data scientists
have a master's and another 47 percent
of data scientists have a PhD so there's
no getting around the fact that in data
science education is not everything but
it absolutely does matter I couldn't
find any such study or breakdown for
business analysts but I do think it's
pretty fair to assume the overwhelming
majority of them will have at least a
bachelor's degree with an increasing
percentage of them having a master's
degree or even an MBA but generally even
though we're in a market where the
overall demand for higher education is
creasing I do think it's fair to say
that the educational requirements for
most data scientist roles will be higher
than the educational requirement for
most business analyst roles however
there are a number of organizations that
provide certifications which are
tailored to the individuals interests
and specialization and those can be just
as helpful if not more helpful than the
academic degree itself next we're going
to talk about everyone's favorite topic
of all which is obviously money
this scientist average salaries have
been studied a bunch of times and the
findings do vary a little bit each time
this is surveyed but you've got
Glassdoor placing the median salary at
about a hundred and thirteen thousand
with the range of that going from 83 K
to 154 K but then there's average
additional cash compensation of about
eleven thousand two hundred dollars
but then indeed found the median base
salary to be a hundred and twenty four
thousand two hundred and twenty-two
dollars so we don't know exactly but it
is fair to say data scientists make a
whole lot of money as far as business
analysts are concerned there was a
global salary survey done by the 2019
International Institute of business
analysis and they found that for men the
average was seventy two thousand nine
hundred and sixty-five and for women the
average was seventy four thousand one
hundred and eighty eight now you get the
idea of the general range of each of
these two positions so business analysts
are going to have less educational
requirement to get their foot in the
door but data scientists do make a bit
more money at least on average and keep
in mind that everything here is based on
averages so these numbers are going to
vary based on your location and region
your industry your years of experience
your certification and these are very
static points which could possibly
change in the future now here's just a
wild prediction that I have about the
future of each of these two roles and I
might be wrong but I have a pretty
strong hunch so take it for what it's
worth I talked about in my video about
will data science die in five years
about how
lot of businesses still say they're not
data-centric and they're not getting
their intended ROI
out of their data department and I made
a point that's probably related about
some parallel problems that workers are
experiencing they're saying they don't
have the support and the infrastructure
that they need and also that the term
data science is not well-defined so what
you end up with is seriously mismatched
expectations both from the
organization's as well as from the
workers themselves so what I think the
next few years will bring is a little
bit more clarity and definition around
the term data science you're gonna see
more complex problems being worked on
and you'll have more of things like ml
engineers who will build start-to-finish
machine learning pipelines but then I
would also expect problems which don't
involve super technical or complex
solutions will be handled a little bit
more by business analysts we're a long
way away from nuanced business problems
just being automated away so if you're a
business and the complexity of your
problems just doesn't require the
technical expertise that a data
scientist has why would you hire one and
pay more to have them solve those
problems you could hire a business
analyst to help with those problems and
you'll end up saving more so that just
seems logical of course if enough
businesses were doing this this would
have the economic effect of increasing
the demand for business analysts
therefore increasing the price of their
labor
aka their salaries all of this happening
while the investment into data and
analytics as a whole just increases thus
making both of these positions more
important and as a result more lucrative
so we will see data gets generated at
enormous rates and there's certain
economic principles that are going to be
true the overwhelming majority of the
time business is always looking for
smarter and more cost-efficient ways to
utilize their data and one of such ways
would probably be to utilize business
analysts more so what you're gonna see
is more demand for that skill set more
competition among employers for that
skill set
and thus forcing them to pay more money
in order to attract that talent all this
ultimately begs the question about which
these two paths is right for you maybe
you're in school right now and you're
interested in data you're pursuing a
statistics Bachelor or something similar
or maybe you work in business analytics
right now and you're thinking about
making a move over to data science now I
actually do think for a lot of people
outside of Silicon Valley the end path
for both of these two careers will look
more similar than you would think
because I think what we're gonna see in
coming years is a lot more industry
experts who can speak technical lingo
but they know their domain really well
and they're working in management maybe
managing teams and they're not
necessarily sitting behind their desk
programming all day so ultimately it's
probably more of a shorter term question
and it comes down to how deep you want
to go into statistics and into the
technical aspects of solving complex
business problems business analysts on
average are going to spend more of their
time with the domain with processes with
storytelling with that side of things
now all that stuff is very important if
you're a data scientist too but a
greater percentage of your world is
going to be taken up by those things if
you're working as a business analyst so
if you genuinely enjoy that side of
things more or things like Business
Administration and processes just appeal
to you more than things like feature
engineering or imputing missing data
you're probably going to enjoy life as a
business analyst a little bit more
likewise if you don't want to pursue a
masters you probably do have a better
chance of becoming a successful business
analyst than you do a data scientist
there are definitely examples out there
of people maybe coming directly out of
college from a bachelor's or
transitioning from one role to another
and becoming a data scientist but I do
have to point out that statistically
those people are the exception rather
than the rule but if you're a person who
loves to nerd out on technical stuff
like advanced statistical models
new packages in Python or
cross-validation of machine learning
models and you also do understand all of
that does lose its value if you're
missing the business expertise or the
ability to communicate about it and also
you have higher education or at least
the prospect of getting it doesn't scare
you off then data science is probably
right for you over all these fields are
both pretty wonderful and nobody can
predict what they're gonna look like in
ten years or even five years from now
but I think it's pretty clear they're
both going to be an extremely high
demand so you truly can't go wrong with
either of them so thanks for watching
this video if you enjoyed it and you'd
like to support my work the most helpful
thing that you could do would be to
share this video otherwise please
consider smashing the like button and
then I'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then Richard on
data